tourisme le tourisme tout court cette
fois était à l'ordre du jour du conseil
municipal de belfort qui veut faire du
tourisme un secteur économique à part
entière
belfort une ville victime d'une mauvaise
image de marque démenti pourtant par les
chiffres de fréquentation des touristes
il n'y a pas de ralentissement du
tourisme
nous avons reçu près de 30000 visiteurs
au château par exemple pendant ces trois
mois d'été et belfort attire un certain
nombre de gens par le château le lion
bien sûr mais aussi à proximité par la
chapelle de le corbusier à ronchamp et
par le ballon d'alsace les lacs qui se
trouvent dans notre région
le ski de randonnée et la randonnée
pédestre simplement la municipalité
entend relancer la politique du tourisme
parce que nous créerons ainsi beaucoup
d'emplois je le croyais ne pouvons aussi
attiré pas mal de gens notamment des
étrangers qui considèrent belfort comme
une ville étape
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons transférer le syndicat
d'initiative au nouveau centre de
belfort passage de france dans ce vaste
plateau piétonnier qui attire des gens
d'ailleurs de toute la franche comté qui
est un lieu d'animations exceptionnelles
mais peut-être qu'il vaudrait que pour
vous en parler je laisse la parole à
notre adjointe à l'animation et au
tourisme madame marie catherine lecoq
mon nous partons de zéro pratiquement en
matière de tourisme nous avons tout à
faire nous allons commencer par faire un
état des lieux
déjà cet été nous avons
fait un pointage des touristes qui
passaient place corbis qui nous a permis
de mieux connaître la clientèle
actuellement de du tourisme belfortain
nous nous sommes aperçus que c'était une
clientèle de passage qui passent en
moyenne une mue et demi à belfort et
donc a priori c'est cette carte là que
nous allons jouer c'est à dire améliorer
l'accueil pour cette clientèle
et si possible attirer un plus grand
nombre de personnes dans notre ville
parce qu'elle fonctionne comme une ville
étape actuellement